so linear transformation
is a function
here we use a here using map notation.
So f is a function that goes from RN to RM.
now a linear transformation can take you from
R3 to R3 or R3 to
R2
so you can actually go from three point to two points or three points to three points
you can
changing transformations
Now this will a linear transformation holds or a
linear transformation is a linear transformation if these two conditions hold.
For example, we have two vectors UV and V.
Then if you take the sum.
of two vectors and remember from abstract from
from tutorial 8
We talked about the following. Let me copy this.
Paste it on top. This is from the other tutorial.
And thank you Richard for correcting me on this killer multiplication. So
I confuse scale a multiplication.
I call a matrix multiplication when I was really referring to the dot
product.
anyway
we said that the sum of two vectors will also be
A third Vector, which means whatever this is, let's say
we get a vector W that will also be an element
in V. So it's good two vectors give you a vector.
A scalar multiplied by Vector gives
you a vector.
and the dot product
which is and this is how you perform a DOT product just multiply the
elements of both
vectors.
Take their sum and you will get the inner product.
We'll be a vector.
so
the sum of the two vectors, which will be a vector must be equal
to
that transformation
of the
of each vector
separately
I mean exactly what you're seeing here.
This condition must hold for addition. And of course this condition for
scalar multiplication must hold.
So for me to elaborate, let's consider these two examples.
So here's a here's an example of a transform linear
transformation.
Okay, no particular reason for using uppercase by the
way, but let's say this is the least so this is map notation.
This is function notation.
So is this a we want to see if this is
a if this is a if this function could be a linear
transformation for two vectors, of course, these are two elements of a
vector but it's still applies
for vectors as well.
here if we take
and just to avoid confusing the
variables because it's variable can
also stand for the sum of two variables. Let me use a
different letter here.
for example
I will use let's use U.
Okay. So, let's see if this is an example if this is if this
is a lean transformation so you we will replace with X
Plus Y X Plus y
So this one argument will be you.
Well X Plus y squared so if we
substitute X Plus Y into U will get X Plus y squared.
Which will give us this.
You know.
quite Relic expression
now if we take f of x and F of Y separately
f of x will give us x squared.
So we replace x with u?
And for wide replace you with Y or give
us x squared plus y squared and clearly this expression
and that expression are not equivalent.
So this is not a linear transformation.
This is an example of a function. That will
be a linear transformation.
Well, and how do you prove that? Well, you must evaluate right
you must.
Take X and Y over 2.
And then to take f of x of this value and
then if y of this value, but anyway if you do the algebra.
You will see that.
They will be equivalent. So what I'm trying to say is this
G of again, I'm gonna substitute x with a
huge to avoid any confusion if we would
take x g of x
plus y
and then we do some algebra.
Dot if you do the algebra, it will turn out that G Plus X.
plus G Plus y
are equivalent
now, of course
Both of these conditions must true must hold true, okay.
So you have to check for that and check for this.
Let's look at an example of a linear transformation and also matrices
can be
We can also do linear Transformations on matrices.
So let me also add this comment.
This idea of matrices as linear transformation will come.
Into play once we talk about once we return
to the topic of systems of linear equations.
and of course computer vision
So our discussion today has applications and finance.
and
computer Visionary later on
when we get to a neural networks.
It was everything by the way a new network is a matrix.
Everything in neural networks, and neural networks are
the infrastructure for deep learning.
It's all Matrix operations. We're going to look at we we're
going to look at a matrix operation
that we haven't talked about like the chronicle product
the kind of evolution.
Which is another way of multiplying two matrices together.
But we'll talk we'll get that later. So here's an example
of a matrix.
As linear Transformations, okay.
we have a times X plus b, so imagine we have
a
system of linear equations
here B
Is what the equations equal to?
so if you remember from linear program we had
I think 2x plus y equals 4000.
So anything's developed rights are the equation would be in there
in the in the B vector.
anyway, if you see here we have two we have
a matrix The Matrix a
which is a 2 by 3 Matrix and the vector.
Which is well.
Three-dimension. It's it's we have three dimensions three points multiply this
Matrix and we go from
three vectors to objective with
three elements to a vector with with two elements
from R3 to R2.
Okay, we will use we will very soon build upon
this.
And return to it once we look at more elaborate
computer vision applications.
So today we will work with the vectors.
Later on, we will work at met with matrices.